what's up you beautiful rejects just
wanted to let you all know that we are
coming to WonderCon Greg Coy and myself
live Sunday March the 26th 11 A.M to
noon come join us for a discussion about
the current state of the MCU and DCU
fandom should be a blast now let's just
jump into it citizens of the reject
Nation welcome to another John and koi
watch DC animated films for the very
first time I am doing great I'm excited
for another big old team of event how
are you going you know why we're gonna
have the team of event because this is
Justice League Gods and Monsters both
Gods and Monsters I'm very intrigued
because this is the name of James guns
chapter one now if you watch these and
enjoy them as always please do like
subscribe comment let us know if you do
think this is going to be any sort of
inspiration for the Gods and Monsters to
come let us know what you think of this
whole series let us know if there's any
certain ones you want us to watch I want
to thank a very special
G fuel oh that's Chris a very special
this is a hype sauce which I feel like
would be my rap name dude
oh my god it feels like a group like a
modern day white Wu-Tang yeah I don't
even know what that'd be I'd be hype
sauce
[Music]
guys there is a discount code in the box
below save yourself 20 a select tub also
like to thank prepper for assembling
these clips we appreciate them very very
much that also being said if you want to
watch this all the way through beginning
to end this whole journey in the movie
can't trade the movie because it's owned
by Warner Brothers we're neither
Brothers Warner but you can watch an HBO
Max over at the patreon where you can
become a super sexy reject and watch our
watching faces
just like that if you want to do it get
over there but if you want to watch us
watch it here stay right here hit play
because we're about to watch Gods and
Monsters
same logo for the first time it's like
we're watching them in order perhaps
who's in the city who's gonna say I
wanna know every time
no one it's because all the Justice
League mine is pure white suspect
it just fit the whole team they just
gathered together the whiteness League
[Music]
depends on who's cast
Krypton that was seismic magnitude 9.8
all I have to do is add my genetic code
just one fingerprint whoa maybe you
shouldn't have said it how loud
damn it you've destroyed this planet I
was given insufficient data please like
the tweaks to his face to make him look
like he is related to Superman yeah my
Army needed the energy your numbers were
inconclusive useless I had the will
I will find him
if anyone's seed is going to be spread
to the heavens it will be mine upon your
egg I bestow my Eminence oh that's hot
ours will be the last child of Krypton
oh is this how it's an else world
because it's Zod baby damn
calzad interesting calzone calzone
sounds great right now after this you
and me straight up calzone time that's
our Shawarma oh yeah dude we should we
should have calzones every time we film
one of these grab your calzone
that it goes together very well like a
Saturday morning cartoon calzone sure
Saturday morning that's all I want now
that man enjoys a good calzone Zod 100
Cal Zod absolutely yeah
oh okay Benjamin Bratt oh
I love this little Michael C Hall Dexter
is also a very different cast Tamara
Taylor I don't think I recognize any of
these names from the past ones yet no
else else world's voices elseworld's
story I'm very intrigued
okay
it's got a very big cinematic scope so
far mm-hmm
and I like that they're doing like an
opening title secret yeah it feels like
a movie like like a real movie a real
movie not like a fake movie like they
draw with these animated things Harry
Styles understands he does a real movie
we love you Harry Styles
[Music]
because
whoa
for a second I thought it's directed by
Seafood
what was he
stock photos directing DC shung Chi
in the sperm vessel I know I love that
the ship even looks like a sperm the art
reminds me more of Superman the animated
series that's why I thought his face
looking so much like Khalil was
interesting
Kent mansley I work for the government
[Music]
he's already out
what was in it the farmer said it was
open when he found it wondering if that
was gonna be him with the hair I want
the ship taken to Star Labs code black
Sergeant none of this gets out the Aging
of Lex is always interesting because I
always think of him as being the same
age as Clark because they grew up
together in the continuity like the main
continuity but if you know maybe Zod was
the one that released him different age
but because they look younger than Mom
I'm very we'll see we'll see choices
Bulletin
interesting way to adjust the
allegorical quality of the Superman
story too yeah Superman where are you we
found their bunker
back super Zod listens to Steve Trevor
American fools oh
jeez
of those deflections oh he's a vampire
who is this reveal yourself
Ah that's cool
oh full blood blood is back that was
intense yeah
kidney shot
hurry God damn it
oh sound Design's great
ah
yes
drain him technically it's often limits
to law enforcement technically we're not
the police the old lady's not gonna like
this she'll be positively orgasmic oh
hello she'll think it's Christmas
I'm pretty sure Michael seals the
vampire which is frankly typecasting let
my man live never gets to not deal with
blood
who watches the watch
and sell stuff yeah I know I love it I
like the capitalism walkthrough
Justice League it's not like we haven't
been warned what the government has said
whoa you have to keep a little
but Fray then
then not you buddy that one change is
odd to him in the whole world that's
cool all those little dots down there
connected to a single productive purpose
a world brought together as one under us
with plenty of protesters you just got
less sexy
oh
foreign
extreme
haven't you seen the thing man kill it
with fire immediately the thing's great
yeah check out koi and Roxy's reaction
when it's up had never seen it
he's got Batman Beyond Vibes I was just
about to say that yeah oh
I like elseworlds this is fun yeah
maybe for the new DCU they could do only
L what the little horse or giant man I
only wish I could be there when the
senate committee gets a load of this
Pony show little horse
molecular miniaturization a big idea for
a shrinking world it's a good slogan Now
where's your horse-sized chicken oh
who'd been on a fight that's the atom
nice remember how you wanted stables in
the backyard
we might have the room after all call me
back
whoa
damn it Terry McGinnis oh it's not the
nicest in this Universal
he's got a Terminator him yeah
but the little horses ah
oh okay at least who made it
no repopulate out in the wild create a
whole new species of horse
I just wanted to destroy this car as you
are a citizen I hate a gas guzzler
big hybrid just making choices with
hybrid people
[Music]
oh no
p52 why'd you have to eat the mini horse
that's the circle of life
many horses are not yet part of the
circle of life this is an Abomination we
had two since when does the Justice
League have a jurisdiction come on Kirk
it's Ray but it's not gonna win me any
friends with the local cops so people
don't like you anyway
and that doesn't bother me at all I'm
bad person one more micro booster and I
could take out a tank now will you tell
me and Dad what was he like what he said
he was tall
he said he had a job for me and I'm
doing it but I did see Wonder Woman tell
me tell me and don't say she was tall
she was
5'4
oh no oh
the hell's that
it's a no move
it's my hero Academia
yeah take out the new moon
oh
yeah he gonna become the cyborg
and then great instincts every Universe
yeah
foreign
I guess we don't get a cyborg in this
Multiverse maybe they'll fuse together
like a Cronenberg cyborg yay cronenborg
cronenborgs I'd watch that I'll write
that comic this is a crime scene I won't
touch a thing your boyfriend has a lot
of nerve he's not my boyfriend and yes
he does is it just made a do her
shoulder plates say hoe
I think your logic will persuade this
guy
still fast can you get back here damn
they just Stone Cold Merc the both of
them
presumably by the ice he hit on the way
down he bled to death yes except they
can't find the blood there should have
been a pool of Frozen blood around the
neck just doing Dexter dialogue too no I
know a lot about blood plasma pooling
someone's actually trying to frame the
Justice League who would have the balls
before the police start putting it
together her shoulders do say how hey
definitive I didn't want to be that guy
no there they are
we've got to get ahead of this thing
that includes the media someone's trying
to screw with us and they're going to be
damn sorry I also like that when he
speaks Spanish there's no subtitles so
it's like just where he's from yeah like
they should have Superman speak like
hella languages it's a cool
I would like yeah right because like why
wouldn't you know the world yeah and he
can't he can't tell me he can't learn a
few languages everything John Henry
hurts
Steele makes it in this world
as long as we get to see steel I'm good
another Cameo he's got a hammer yeah
is that Luther in the middle
you okay I gotta finish my lab work oh
before he was a vampire you're coming to
the party tonight you don't want to make
Tina mad you know how she gets given to
peer pressure
no
it's okay man you'll find love yeah or
vampirism one of the two yeah something
with hearts you're missing the party
sorry but I think I'm getting close to
something the coefficient on the blood
coagulants is almost matching hey get
your ass up we're late yeah you nerd
put away the bat stats just for one
night for me for you okay that's enough
convincing let's move move crazy Ivy's
bringing her homegrown oh homegrown uh
oh I like that's relationship to plants
in this city yeah loves the herb yep
that don't make sense I respect it
probably have to use college she must be
yeah she'd make the best mushrooms
poison ivy mushrooms oh
you okay
yeah I feel fine is there garlic in here
this designated driver is going home but
baby I'm the designated boyfriend you
need to drive me come on oh whoa whoa
the bat Venom almost eradicates the
lymphoma but the cell structure breaks
down even as it forms
the oh
Dr Michael morbius just ignore I thought
they were like it's fine I can't say
that I understand it all but I see what
you mean about using nanotech is that my
research how did you get my password
Batman yeah he's not gonna get any
better lying on his ass anyway school's
over
we could use a science project this is
my favorite polyamorous relationship
yeah they're very cute
also he just threw much mice in the
trash that's messed up I think you did
it will you laid the brick I just
plastered we could still use another
test no oh yeah Orbee isn't up let's do
this it's Mormon time just look away
Jesus here even animated man yeah I
don't like needles they managed to make
me uncomfortable with drawing
oh
no whoa
whoa
whoa nice
that's how he knows Give In To The
Thirst bite his head like a Lost Boy
hey
vampire with a reflection cause he's a
bad man
[Music]
foreign
looked like him
branding like Batman it's always got
symbols yeah bat drive this is much more
of a boys-esque universe it very much
especially the relationship between
Superman and one woman yeah would Mr
Trevor's investigation include the
Justice League I don't know if you've
read the crime reports Pete but they
have some nasty implications
oh speak of the devil mind if I come in
by all means it's not often we get a
strange visitor from another planet what
brings you I like Superman hovering
ominously instead of like as hope yeah
sneaking up on people the fact is he was
working for me on what I could show you
if you'd like you never let the Press
inside the tower I'm reconsidering like
hell let's go adios Mio the building
would provide a shield that makes it
virtually impenetrable my God even the
rumors about this place don't do it
justice
justice league
[Music]
It's gotta say it yep now we know
definitely Superman confirmed files were
heavily damaged during the ship's Trek
to Earth that's why I enlisted Professor
Stones help all we have are the last
moments on Krypton
Daddy
this is straight up spin control so here
I am getting the full court press on the
man of Steel's Human Side that's not an
oxymoron Luther was a frustrated elitist
whose influence was Wayne I was raised
by a migrant couple I've seen the
harshness of life but I'm here when my
country needs me and where's Lex Luthor
gone sorry to interrupt but there's a
call on the Justice phone
it's a fun Tech I like the parenting
pivot to like how he perceives the world
needless to say this is a conversation
we never had but I want you to know that
forensics Amanda Waller president Waller
if things get difficult I won't be able
to protect you protect me from who who
do you think protects whom
you know politically protected you get
it man definitely got them grammatically
though that whole who whom things pretty
good
his Professor Magnus available
they are all a bunch of cold-blooded
Killers not Kirk
he can vampire for Christ's sakes he
only kills criminals just because your
best buddies doesn't mean you're safe if
freeze and the others are on their list
we all are and I'm not just gonna sit
around and wait to see who's next so
this runs a lot of authority I'm really
curious if this is the way that gun's
gonna play that she's under the
impression that the Justice League is
killing off America's greatest
scientists she's a scientist she sees
patterns what aren't you telling me will
um
stupid this is stupid I want to take an
EQ test that's cool but if I thought
there was anything you should know
I wouldn't hold back what about project
fair play Mr terrific fair play
it appears to be a program Luthor
started what does it have to do with
this nothing Kirk if I knew I would tell
you Kirk oh what's going on oh your
husband isn't much help you know how
will is so sure of himself he can be too
clever for his own good Willie Style
don't worry I won't let anything happen
to you or will
you either 10. thank you
all MVP we're urine as much danger as
any of us I know the skin is cold but
the heart's still warm
kiss right in front of will just get
that polyamorous relationship just
settle it
pretty good with the bow staff
Steve Trevor Wonder Woman you don't fool
me Becca I know why you're here you want
to know what forensics has
she's dressed like one of the new Gods
so I'm curious her Origins here
how about a wager I win I get the
information you win you get me
hey
we both know you're 50 times stronger
than I am
it's not about strength it's about
agility we can both get what we want oh
you think the big guy's gonna like that
it's not my boyfriend
oh I belong to no man not Superman not
me
so long for that info piss off Wonder
Woman you belong to someone once
this is
I told you that in a moment mentioned
405 I'm impressed all right all right
Ray Palmer's body was found slashed in
half they're pretty sure they've id'd
the weapon it's only the leg press in 90
but he's mentioned 405 don't skip leg
day bro I saw that leg press machine not
important man I just want those biceps
just want to be top heavy Steve Trevor
tomorrow at this time we not only merge
kingdoms but families
yeah Mr Miracle first time I've seen him
in anything animated hey history will
praise your courage and sacrifice you
have a world counting on you and get
some sleep
we have a momentous day ahead of us
feels like a Bible movie right now yeah
swords in the sandal like sci-fi epic
yeah
oh
[Music]
this thing with DC live action you could
do is there's so many different tones
and worlds they could play with like New
Gods is crazy Rich we're going to find
out I'm not much for rules I also tend
to get my way hop on no thank you you're
not afraid are you I'm never afraid
come with me
get on my floating treadmill show new
world don't you dare hold tighter than
that this is
straight up is Aladdin
I love it
shining shimmering splendid
you know if you sync up this with the
Aladdin soundtrack it actually totally
plays the Warner Brothers Disney collab
that never happened the amalgam Universe
this is my special spot this is where I
come to think about what
you
eyebrow maintenance
it's for you
oh blade was forged by our finest
swordsmith it's virtually indestructible
inside the pommel is a mother box it
will take you anywhere you want to go oh
damn what a gift it is my wedding gift
keep it at your side the sword will
protect you when I cannot as a boss
proposal it's a good move
oh little nose nuzzle kill the moment
look at them I think of Orion as a bit
more of a dick in the comics but
elseworld maybe he's the good guy gotta
twist him somehow gotta make it work I
now declare your spirits as well
or a whole movie about that one oh
granny goodness is fantastic I love her
oh that's granny good yeah oh okay I
want Margo Martindale to play her can
you imagine a Marga Martindale granny
goodness New Gods movie oh so good the
movie I never knew I absolutely needed
I'd watch a solo granny goodness movie
and it's Marco martial never miss man so
good come let's go Becca
look we can be together
oh oh no
I mean his people are being eradicated
damn
oh
right in the chin
whoa for nope side should have gone with
her boy
oh
oh what life could you have had with him
wow he was darkseid's blood one of
countless bastards in a line of endless
betrayal good touch with the eyes I
would have worn them all I would have
shouted to the skies trust not the
Monster High father he is mad with power
silence damn
mother boxed out yeah now I'm an
Earthling kinda oh I was wondering how
she was a new God's Wonder Woman that's
really interesting be there as soon as I
can
oh he's got to do Batman stuff right
maybe we should go public it'll be in
the government side let's make them mad
at us too it's not as if they're
protecting us
oh yeah
School each one is like sort of subtly
designed after them then yeah I like
that all right guys maybe not so subtly
but yeah
the other thing about these else words
is you could just Mark any American
fools left and right of this rating
[Music]
wow that's a horrible way to go
oh
whoa
damn
come on bat Dexter
oh no
I'm not into that going well
Holly gonna do
oh oh
but but her unrequited love for
the thrupple is over oh wow damn dude
everybody cold
survivors didn't expect it who are you
I mean that's pretty fast yes I know but
it's a thing
everyone's dead I hear heartbeat
oh
Freddy Krueger we got a house full of
dead scientists and we're no closer to
solving this thing there is someone who
could help but you're not gonna like it
oh who we got who we got who we got yeah
he's he's in outer space Luther
the most likes Luther will stare down
little button press wowie what a good
cool
he's just taking his sweet ass saunter
in great use of of the hovering the
whole video yeah I began it years ago in
case the human race needed to neutralize
the Justice League
Superman in case we have to kill
the kill just in case you weren't clear
on what I meant I'm gonna spell it out
real quick the Justice League may be a
three-headed Hydra but there's only one
head that truly counts you've hated me
from day one unassailable power is never
to be trusted and you're a Mexican
Luther real racist if you're pulling the
strings Luthor again you misread me I
never really cared for power what I
coveted was knowledge oh knowledge is
power though most of this is based on
Kryptonian science which I downloaded
from the ship that brought you to Earth
those files were damaged no
you bastard you had no right those files
are mine they're my legacy would you
like to see your legacy oh his name was
jorel
the leading scientist on The Planet
Krypton
the woman is his wife Lara your mother
Alexa gets to break him
oh boy he drilled into krypton's core to
power his military machine a fatal
mistake it's not everyone who can
witness their own conception sure why
did you keep this from me I was afraid
you'd emulate your father better you
should think he was a hero but you are
no hero you're just a pit bull
Mr worldwide
project fair play worked they can kill
you now if they want in some ways on as
much your creation as my father's wow I
like they knew where the camera was yeah
I'm gonna make this ominous
oh
I mean how to frame him Luther's ship
was destroyed then they've killed them
all we start fair play evacuate
Metropolis
we could give ourselves up get a lawyer
someone out there is playing us and
we're not going to find him in police
custody who's the best lawyer in the DC
Universe Matt Murdoch get The
Amalgamated going a hell of a webcast
if we live through it on that camera
yeah yeah you know it's it's Wi-Fi
compatible
cool nice
again great use of the float like why
walk if you can ominously hover
oh
what did you
oh no whoa
oh
I had two tin gotta be killed by your
friends
oh you can't leave him
whoa I don't want a choice why does she
have robot nips
sucker looked into this moment
we have a witness to our innocence
recovering inside you'll see him when I
say not this time buddy
oh you got Kryptonite in there
Keepers cool nice
yep yeah this is only gonna get uglier
where is Tina she's dead I killed her
what about a year into our marriage it
was an accident I assure you bro see I
always knew she loved bro even back in
college she was only really happy when
the three of us were together uh even
after I turned you into a monster even
after that she still wanted you oh wow
will will will she never let up and
finally one day I'd had it and I hit her
had struck a table oh that's when I came
up with her twin
she's made from a platinum isotope that
can mimic human flesh
when I killed Tina I had a revelation
Kirk we're capable of such a monstrous
act then what hope is there for Humanity
change the world like Luther said no
more personal anguish no
no more guilt fine piece of [__]
everyone's worst yep
we'll plan a nanite into someone's head
everyone will be connected as one even
the Justice League so why haven't you
done this already I needed an energy
source strong enough to power it
foreign
they've got that in-house he is the
perfect Cipher for all of humanity I
mean he gets it
oh yeah oh
this is pretty devastating
I want to point a helicopter at another
helicopter sometimes we gotta do oh get
us out
peace
neutralize Your Mother Box Wonder Woman
buy the gods it was good use there
that's clever at the connection of one
Roman and this Wonder Woman I like that
shoot with that giant webcam in this
universe
I thought he was dead
unfortunately I can't teleport through
those walls Trevor you asked
it's Magnus if we don't stop him he's
going to take our minds or die for one
would like to keep mine
and so Luther teams up with Superman
again activate the ship's core activate
the butt shot I mean it's just leaning
all the way in I watched one madman
destroy my home world I'm not going to
let another harm this
becoming the hero that's right oh no
oh buddy he has to go again
[Music]
oh oh vampire vampire oh there he is
let's do this
get out of my house
[Applause]
my penthouse I like to get off my plane
moment for grizzled Harrison Ford
Superman
oh yeah Mega Batman Beyond villain guy
now his logo's a donut
this doesn't stand for Hope stands for
snacks
oh
just like those things from my hero
Academia
I mean there's got to be some level of
inspiration I would imagine it seems
like it
even looks like the girl from The
Authority it is really interesting that
we'll talk about it after now let's just
start the review right now right now
right right is the third Act is
crescendoing maybe people will actually
watch the review now
teaser it's over will
not yet
how do you like them apples I've made a
fairly strong recovery
oh
ah man I'd strength
there it is
burned all your mother boxes no more
Disappearing Acts for you
yeah sometimes it's a punch in the face
that's what you gotta do a Superman
punch
yeah yeah
melt them oh that's awesome
so hardcore
yes yes lava punch oh it's metal
[Music]
starting to crack
boo Alex Mack
[Music]
this guy reminds me so much of Rob Stark
oh yeah his name
Richard Madden yeah there you go there
you go you'd be a good Batman sure
oh jeez nanites yeah
what do they do everything
let's go more bats
that's good more badass I like it yeah
phew who only left your bats in test
tubes wrong I love two people in my life
and now they're both gone it was a
polyamorous relationship beautiful thing
ruined
what's up
[Music]
peace I'm not sure what would harm a
liquid metal woman
ah clever
she sent her to the sun
everybody's got to go to the Sun or a
magma pitch gotta melt them down punch
the nail lights out
go ahead bet you taste like crap
does taste like nanites
ship's core is destabilizing oh
come on Superman
fly that damn sperm ship to the Stars
Superman
funny
after a while you don't even recognize
yourself anymore
well I mean your face is pretty mangled
Forgive Me Kirk
oh
this is part one pipe that's the way to
go I just
we need to shake things up a bit change
the way we do things no more politics no
more killing
okay I'm a vampire
it's time already
ceremonial Cape our beautiful Becca is
leaving us the problems of my past
linger in ways yours do not it's time I
went back and faced them she has a
co-conspirator
oh
you come to me if you need help
I have something for you too Superman
you're in the original files from your
ship no aren't they supposed to be with
the government you know how things get
lost in bureaucracies be a real hero my
man yay acknowledge is power shall we
please allow me you go Jean Gray and
Professor X
yeah hover chair bald guy redhead super
power Duo yes do this man I'm here for
it why don't we get started I could use
a science project time to look ahead
Kirk the past is like another planet
[Music]
best throttle best throttle rest in
peace the moral is lean into polyamory
at the cost of the world's sake
otherwise yep absolutely Jason Isaacs
was Lex Luthor okay Baker was right yes
sometimes how old pageant Brewster was
Lois Lane all right I was wrong we got a
D Bradley yeah doing the ray Palmer work
not bad not bad Yuri was Jarrell that's
awesome Yuri's voice is Spider-Man PS4
buddy of mine love that man oh what it
do what it do that's good to see that's
what's up
Amanda Waller created by credit I like
seeing comic names in here we got some
Marvel Wolfman John burn Jerry Ordway
John ostrand or Louis Simonson John
Bogue to Navi I don't actually know that
name uh Neil Adams Jack Kirby
good to see the love good
uh I struggled with that one really oh
let's hear it I think that my okay so
I've talked uh at a decent length about
my struggle with animation and
connecting with characters because I
connect with like the actor's
interpretation the the soul of the actor
my association with the actor my
association with the character all those
things so I generally am a live action
person because of that
I think since I didn't know this world I
didn't know this else world like I will
totally own that I didn't know who
people were I don't know if what this is
based off of this was not something I
was familiar with since I didn't know
the IP since I didn't know the
characters since I didn't know uh how to
connect I really struggled to be
invested in anyone because I didn't have
the Baseline and I think this is one of
the examples where animation when it's
an adaptation of the story I know I can
put myself beyond my struggle but since
I didn't know the story and it was
animated I struggled with it
I can see what you mean I had a lot of
fun watching this but it does feel like
if I had if this was like the sequel to
something yeah I would have felt
probably a lot more
deeply invested it's like I was really
interested in the ideas and the and it
was really fun to be presented with
these takes on the characters uh but
yeah it's like I don't walk out of this
feeling like I have a great idea of who
Kirk is or who Becca is right or you
know that uh side of it and I feel like
they make so many interesting choices
especially like I love that uh little
Superman you know lands on the other
side of the border and comes up in a
different way and like that's something
I would watch you know even more
flashbacks right right right and like
how that changed his perspective on like
how and how they raised him yeah and
it's like they they did
and they put in an effort to like
disperse these flashbacks throughout the
movie where you see you know the sort of
origin of Kirk's version of Batman and
you see what happened with uh Wonder
Woman before she came to Earth and all
that stuff or at least in this you know
iteration came to Earth yeah and and
yeah like those things were really
interesting and I almost feel like this
while very fun and enjoyable to me would
have played yeah with much deeper
investment had we seen those as like
movies or something like any sort of
connection I feel like would have and
like I'm connected to the voice actors
like I was invested in Batman because
Michael C Hall but I wasn't that
invested in this Batman like and they
gave us a lot of backstory on this
Batman they that was kind of the core of
it and I just couldn't find myself going
like I want to be in this story more and
like Wonder Woman's backstory is great
because I care about the new gods in a
unique way but like I never felt fully
immersed like seeing this image of
Superman Wonder Woman Batman I'm more
interested the one with the background
and that's hard because that's just like
the Loyalty I have for those archetypal
characters like those are the characters
I'm with and I was wondering when I
watched like um the Batman and Robin uh
movie that kind of played the grant
Morrison stuff right since I knew that I
was excited for like seeing some of the
things adapted to animation but Turtles
and versus Batman like there's no
there's no Canon comic that I could have
read to be adapted for but since I love
the turtles and love Batman I was
excited for that playfulness so I think
it's uniquely when it's fully removed
and that often makes me wonder if that's
how people that aren't invested in comic
boom we've watched them like maybe
that's how Scorsese sees them like you
know he's just the one you bring up like
I don't think Scorsese is the villain of
the story a lot of people think that
when I say that I'm like screws who are
sizzy I'm not saying that I'm saying he
might not invest in much the way that I
struggle to invest in things like this
yeah I can absolutely see that and two
yeah it's like I would imagine that
partly maybe if I can lay an assertion
maybe what helps with uh you know your
investments into various of these
animated movies is that yeah you have
certain of those touchstones with not as
necessarily like a physical face of an
actor but you know you have the
character their legacy this comic book
all of my association with all of your
association with that stuff and yeah
here yeah it's like I can imagine this
Scorsese not having any of those things
coming into various you know superhero
even live action movies and being like
yeah you know
uh may be fun but yeah I'm not really
super invested or moved by any of this
yeah and uh and yeah it's like I can
because I think the way this Justice
League is portrayed and you know it's
like Kirk Batman is very s yeah yeah
very stoic and and very sort of calm of
energy and even Superman is sort of
similarly stoic yeah it's like they all
have attitude they all have personality
but they all are a bit reserved a bit
stoic and I I don't know there's like
some kind of dynamic that could have
bridged it's like if you had like at
least one like overtly fun character tie
it together or things like that like the
seven has uh elements of like nuanced uh
passion even beyond the stoicness of
like homelander right like but
homelander you get to invest in a
different way but even with homelander
you need other characters to buoy that
and then you've got the boys who you're
rooting and four while enjoying the
seven we don't really have the island of
the boys here we don't really have the
Steve Trevor backstory we don't really
have anyone that we're like the eye line
of yeah and I think that you know
starting this out with your preconceived
notions of like okay Zod and the
destruction of Krypton and oh wait okay
so this is you know zod's child now and
and uh Lara uh zorrell and all that
stuff and uh and so
I feel like because you're already
getting used to and swallowing that uh
you know that then adds to those other
elements of of you know the personality
portrayals and and things like that that
makes yeah something that amounts to
something that has like more interesting
ideas than like a truly uh synthesized
execution yeah like and again like I I
don't dislike this and I had a lot of
fun with it but but yeah it is I'm glad
to have seen it but I definitely am uh
this brought out all the flaws that I
have with my experience like and I'm not
judging this it's how I perceive it yeah
and it's like I almost wish this had
been like an hour and a half or
something like that something I don't
even know what 10 or 15. yeah just
because I think just to to really let
you endear to these different takes on
these characters because I think there
is an element where because they are an
edgier version of the team I don't think
in the first half until it really
becomes clear that they're being set up
and then they decide to be more
benevolent in the way that they go about
you know helping the citizens of Earth I
feel like you spend the first half going
like am I do I like these guys I also
like these guys am I sure I'm supposed
to root for these guys like yeah and and
not that you can't have compelling
anti-heroes and stuff like that but it
just wasn't a hundred percent I wasn't
sure if I was going to you know be
rooting against these guys at some point
you know for a little while anyway and
that's also tricky the DC animated films
being so edgier with their Superman
being so edgier with their Wonder Woman
and and that's what I I started alluding
to earlier was the authority is a team
of Heroes that operate above government
that operate outside of the law that
like do their own thing that's a
commentary in the Justice League like
midnighters Batman Apollo is Superman
but what's interesting is this is very
similar in those parallels in that the
female lead of authority actually looks
like that robotic woman and that uh the
portrayal of Apollo and midnight are
they weren't a couple here but they were
more dark and more leaning into killing
I'm wondering if if it's called Gods and
Monsters what James Gunn is building I
don't think he's adapting this by any
means but I'm wondering now if there'll
be a story similar to this with the
authority where we don't know if we like
them and then as we invest in them there
is that face turn versus a heel turn
yeah and we start a movie with a darker
edgier team like this and then there's a
moment where we realize we rely on them
yeah and I wouldn't have necessarily
assumed that without this gods and
monster subtitle and like what does it
mean for James Gunn making Gods and
Monsters will we see New Gods things
will we see Mr Miracle McDonald which is
my dream will we see the the whole world
they they describe here because of this
subtitle I'm really curious how the
subtitle relates to what this thing
James Gunn is building with his giant
chapter one which he just revealed is
only half revealed which is crazy
I know well that's the fun part too is
all that all that all that extra stuff
to look forward to and yeah the the
adaptation therein of just this like is
there is there like a definitive Gods
and Monsters Comics I don't not there
probably is I I'm not nearly as versed
to know yes or but not not one of which
I don't know well renowned you know like
you know classic Arts not like the
Batman and Robin I need a reference in
the woman like the stuff that is
reference nothing jumps to mine I'm sure
there is and I'm sorry audience that's
going to be very mad but I forgot some
classic Neil Adams story or something
but not to my knowledge and I didn't
know this so it was really interesting
to to learn yeah and I mean this totally
had elements where I could see certain
uh at least thematic and aesthetic
qualities carrying over into whatever
James Gunn's making here and I mean this
certainly felt akin to like a Snyder
take on these things absolutely in fact
watching this I had a thought where I
was like man Zack Snyder should have
made like a bunch of elseworlds [__]
that's what I always thought about his
movies is their their Immaculate else
worlds and the authority walked so the
boys could run so whenever we had boys
moments in this this came out in 2015
The Authority came out in 99 or 2000
okay and that allowed the boys to thrive
in o6 the boys come out no six so there
are there have always been like uh
Squadron supreme but Marvel yeah the
comic boys uh because I came out my
senior high school and I remember
reading it being like Oh my God because
the book is even more depraved than the
show
uh my buddy Derek Robertson's the artist
on that and it's crazy seeing how kind
and sweet of a guy he is when I was
exposed to him by like what the [__] but
that said Squadron Supreme was the
Marvel version of like the Avengers
being dark and and there's always been
commentary like this
Zack Snyder did really good commentary
on it but it never felt like the
characters no disrespect Snyder fans
that said the authority when he
announced I was like oh that's genius
he's gonna allow a darker commentary in
Universe yeah and then things like this
allow for that but we still need to
connect to them for the commentary to
work and I do feel like it took longer
than was healthy for the for the movie's
sake yeah and it's funny because this
movie thinking back on all the all of
these that we've watched now and and you
know when we eventually if we ever
eventually do whatever makes sense uh
I'm very excited but but it's it's now
that we've seen a few and we have some
that are like oh these are yeah slam
dunk dynamite and then they're they're
luckily there haven't been any like oh
that was tough so far but there are at
least a couple where we've been like oh
yeah like this was fun but I had my
issues with it and of all I would put
that in this category yeah I would say
that of all the ones we've had that
response to this one I think had the
most my favorite array of intriguing
ideas it's like
in the immediate experience of it sure
there's more they could have done to
endear me to this set of characters to
this Take on the World to just make me
not you know be aware of or self-aware
sort of feeling like am I supposed to
what am I supposed to feel right now
yeah I do think that this has my
favorite array of just Concepts because
I really like their Superman here I
really like this take on the Zod based
Superman and again his origin and how
that is different and then seeing the
new Gods adjustment with Wonder Woman
and having Batman be morbius like and
Lex Luthor like I love the idea of Lex
Luthor here I think I was the most
thematically invested like you're saying
but the story didn't grab me as much as
most of the other ones so it's
interesting that I was thinking of the
themes more than my connection to the
character yeah
because yeah it's like you look at like
a Justice League War and like that's
really fun it's very immediate but when
it's done you kind of that's kind of it
yeah it's kind of it doesn't leave you
with that much more to reflect versus
somehow Batman versus turtles or like
Arkham like there's some that I'm just
like like some of them I'll re-watch for
the pure fun of it yeah and this is more
like I like the themes presented yeah
and that's that's an interesting
difference of experience yeah and this
is one where where I would love to see
more of these themes extrapolated
somewhere but but yeah it is it is kind
of an interesting just just balancing of
the different tenets and themes because
yeah in some ways I'm most conflicted
about this this has certain aspects that
I like the most but also you know where
a Justice League War maybe falls short
and having you know that much more
substance it's still like very immediate
and it gives you a couple clear-cut like
I don't know about this characterization
however just the Journey of having fun
being with the Justice League there's
not too much to swallow to know where
your footing is in that world so it is
interesting and yeah fun uh weird
headcanon that just happened I always
thought before Charlie Cox was cast and
showed the perfect narrative Charlie
Cox's genius is Daredevil uh Michael
cial will be a great Daredevil oh red
hair uh has like that very intense Focus
has that really great delivery like he
was always in my head like when Dexter
was on I always thought of him before
Charlie Cox uh
but it was funny I've always thought of
not Batman and Iron Man paralleling
because that's the obvious one but the
subtext of Bruce Wayne and Matt Murdoch
paralleling I've always thought of Matt
Murdock and and that character is much
more like a Batman like I've always
thought of when I think of the the
parallels of Daredevil and Batman I
think of that before the the Bruce Wayne
like Iron Man thing that everybody else
talks about he's everywhere in Batman
yeah so it was funny watching this
hearing Batman as Dexter and my brain
going like that was my Daredevil and it
was just like after all these years it
was just funny to have an experience
like that's the closest I'll probably
get but that was kind of nice and
elseworld Daredevil does answer my Noob
question here does does Marvel's got two
lawyers in their roster who are Jennifer
Walters and Matt Murdoch at least yeah
who are arguing the law
in the DC Universe when you asked that I
was like racking my brain I was like is
there a version where Martian Manhunter
decides to be a lawyer he's like you
know what I'm gonna use this data to get
my bar I'm gonna pass the bar as Martian
Manhunter
it does seem like like a Trope that you
would still want to have in Universe
it's really fun but I I also feel like
in Universe DC does less
um full issue attention on the secret
identity character sure they're very
much gods that walk amongst us whereas
like Marvel and this is just black and
Whiting a very color scale but Marvel is
very much what would it be like if
everyone had the ability to get powers
and the every man had powers versus DC
always felt like what if these these
beings were amongst us yeah like there's
I've always seen that slight separation
I think that's why we're less about the
secret identity again that's not not
always the case like Kyle Raynor I
consider much more amongst us than Hal
Jordan like there's just a different
flavor but I think that makes it like me
thinking of their jobs as less common
because I don't think of what they do
like day to day I think about like their
super heroics yeah that makes sense but
I think that's also I hope the more I
read DC that might shift uh that's also
what I hope to see from Clark Kent as
Intrepid reporter uh like and and I
think like John Kent which is a very
interesting character in the comics
right now I'm very invested in his
day-to-day life as well as him as a hero
and I think the modern society like I
think in the 40s 50s 60s even 70s we
wanted to think of a Larger than Life
characters and now I think invested in
both versions of them because we want
that Nuance so yeah that's I think
that's part of
I don't know I feel like each of these
kind of begs a little sprinkling of the
thing that they're not as focused on
right in DC it's like yeah I love the
idea of Gods and Monsters and and
looking up instead of looking around
right but also you know like the human
the human exploration is still very
interesting and that's part of the
contrast I think these characters exist
to create and I think you know you look
at like a character like Superman and
even though I feel like Superman Clark
Kent has more of like an ingrained
presence than maybe even a Bruce Wayne I
mean like those two to me of DC's
characters have the most ingrained like
public alter egos I don't know exactly
how much time is devoted to exploring
those in the comments well that's why I
like Bruce Wayne so much is because
these three characters not just two like
there's the mask of Bruce the real Bruce
and then the the Batman but that's why I
thought the Batman was so excellent is
because the Bruce Wayne mask hasn't been
developed yet yeah so everyone that said
Pattinson played him underdeveloped it
was like no no he hasn't developed the
need for the character that that is
Bruce Wayne and that's why I think long
Gaming's the Batman is going to be so
incredibly like passionate and
interesting because he's gonna he's
gonna we're gonna see him in real time
make the thing we connect with falsely
yeah and like that's what makes these
characters so interesting is you can you
can layer them so many different ways
that's another conversation sure and
that's what's interesting about these
because you know these are compact
movies all of them they're all roughly
an hour and 10 to 15 minutes and
it's like each time is a bit of a dice
roll because I I'll just never say that
it's not possible because I've seen
certain of these certain of these land
that even have a lot to you could argue
that Batman versus Ninja Turtles or
something like that has a lot to do or a
flash point is a lot to do in an hour
and 15 minutes and manages often and
manages without ever feeling slight or
feeling like it's that brief of a run
time or anything like that and so
something like this I I think kind of
feels like oh yeah there was a lot of
stuff in here and it was all neat and
interesting but it didn't get quite a
chance to all be fleshed out in a way
that I could a hundred percent invest in
yeah
um which is just like you know it's
bound to happen but I do think it's
interesting because now having seen
enough of these I'm like well you know
it's enough it seems like enough time
I've seen stories
that seemed you know maybe a little more
fleshed than this did yeah um and I but
I also think it's the type of story they
chose to tell like I didn't understand
the new gods in the comics I didn't
connect with them until Mr Miracle which
is a fairly recent comic from Tom King
and Mr odds that basically made
scot-free my eye line to the new Gods I
didn't feel like we had an island in the
new guts and so like things like that
make it so there's a disconnect that
even time I don't know if it would help
a lot of this did have that sort of
Disconnect just kind of all around like
even a Lois Lane isn't really an eye
line or anything right and Jimmy I
assume was the webcam guy with the giant
thing operator wouldn't even know his
name no he's in the CIA I mean obviously
he's been he's been killed years ago but
that I think is going to do it for this
this episode of uh John and Coy watch DC
animated For the First Time title
pending uh I even this isn't my bottom
three but even this I'm so glad to have
seen and that is a testimony the power
of DC animated like even the ones that
I'm not like but I I do want to
acknowledge the the difference in
layering because we will at some point
rank them and I just feel like if we
just love everything that's not fair to
them so this one is in the lower scale
but uh still very glad to have seen it
uh let us know in the comments which one
you want us to watch next let us know
what you thought of Gods and Monsters
and let us know if you think this is
maybe a play on The Authority that might
get adapted later and also when did um
my hero Academia start oh it was before
2015.
because now I'm curious about the Nobu
wait what are they called Nobu is a
restaurant no I was like that's almost
right
all right let's find out this series
begins 2018 really that's it oh that's
Statewide that's in the states though
okay okay okay the first season aired uh
in Japan up through April 2016. original
run says July 7 2014 to present so it
sounds like the nomu in this were
simultaneous okay because this came out
2015 that would have been developing it
in 2014. interesting yeah if you know in
the comments if nomu inspired these or
this inspired no more or just parallels
let us know if this is a common
character I don't know and I failed you
I apologize again I'm trying to learn uh
that is going to do it for this episode
thank you thank you thank you like
subscribe comment appreciate you we'll
see you next time patreon shout out
patreon shout out let's get it
Anissa what's up Anissa Oliva one of our
most enduring one of our dyest hardest
patrons here at the patreon page of the
super sexies and dies hard absolutely
like it's over a hundred percent in fact
you should create some kind of you know
brand based off your name right I like
that it's got vowel letter vowel letter
initial vowel like like Anissa Oliva
like there's a there's a I have a
pentameter to it you know what I mean
there's there's like a rhythm it's like
a very specific roller coaster I like
that it's got an eye centered a a like
it's a it's a very aesthetically
pleasing visually name and it sounds
good nice work parents dude yeah they
did good work solid they really did you
have a nice symmetrical
arrays
like Cinder eyes and vowels all around
you have a very yeah you have a very
symmetrical and very both visually but
also hourly pleasing name yeah which is
so cool not every name you know has that
ring but yours do as a koi genre uh you
also have a Star Wars looking name like
my name looks like a Star Wars character
so does yours I think it's all the
vowels like if you look at my name
visually right it looks fake it does and
Anissa Oliva probably understands that
exact plate
that's a cool position to be in if
you're if you're not resentful welcome
to the club and you say leave a cool
name club and May the force be with you
both thank you